bonjour, je suis Alistair Petri également
connu sous le nom de croissance principale, mais aujourd'hui, je
vais être historien de l'art alors que nous
examinons cette galerie exquise Otis sur une
roue entraînante de Brie
Eric posant la vieille question
il m'aime il m'aime pas
basé sur  un jeu français Lily et ses
violettes un symbole grec de l'amour lesbien et
bisexuel notre jeune comédienne avec un
clin d'œil à Shakespeare dr.  Jeanne Milburn une
grenade le symbole de la fertilité le
ps/2 soulève das Eric et Adam je me demande
ce qui est en magasin pour ces deux chérubins
eh bien je suppose que nous devrons le découvrir dans la
saison trois ne vous
vous